vous appelez un point sur les quelques
d'histoire qui avec vincent lagaf ce qui
a beaucoup de gens que ça intéresse
regardez c'est parti entre 6,8 et
vincent lagaf les relations n'ont pas
toujours été simples ces derniers mois
le 12 avril dernier la gaffe annonce son
arrivée sur la chaîne et signe son
contrat en direct dans tpm p je suis ému
un mois plus tard il lance strike pour
la première fois en prime sur ces 8 et
le public répond tout de suite présent
mais il ne faudra pas attendre longtemps
pour que cette belle histoire ses cornes
dès l'été la presse relate que
l'animateur ferait de nombreux caprices
notamment quant à l'heure de début des
émissions un comportement qui était mal
passer auprès des chroniqueurs de tpm
pcf à lui de décider qu est-ce qui va
faire grimper le droit ou pas tolérer un
directeur de programme qu'elle a pour sa
nouvelle sortie de l'animateur cette
fois ci sur rtl où il fait un appel du
pied à tf1 de façon plutôt décomplexée
si tf1 me dis ton idée d'émission de
sports mécaniques nous branche
on la veut le dimanche après midi et j'y
vais en cours alors que vincent lagaf ne
s'est pas exprimé depuis cette sortie il
est temps de connaître toute la vérité
alors justement j'ai eu longuement
vincent lagaf voilà au téléphone pour me
poser toutes les questions bien entendu
déjà on a vu jean michel mr et vincent
la vincent vous répond il dit monsieur
maire durant mais presque quarante ans
de carrière dont 20 ans de télé sur quoi
vous basez vous pour affirmer que j'ai
pris le melon ma franchise ou peut-elle
les yeux je ne me souviens pas vous
avoir fréquenté une seule fois dans ma
vie professionnelle ou privée
c'est donc un préjugé voilà il vous aide
je me bats sur le sur le travail des
excellents journalistes dont parlait
tout à l'heure gilles ils ont fait une
enquête pour dire un peu ce qu'ils
réclamaient ils réclament pas de queue
de miss on commence à une heure pile
exact à son cv par an oui oui alors ils
auraient ils réclament ne se laissait
pas de sens qui fait ça c'est non mais
attendez c'est normal il essaie
d'optimiser son programme il est il est
parti sur une nouvelle aventure avec
strike il envie voilà c'est normal c'est
l'europe les autres le font non tous les
autres 25 oui alors je vais vous dire il
y relate alain caprice d'un meilleur
c'était banzaï avec coluche il va pas
mal donc il ya très peu d'émissions de
flux sur ces huit donc forcément
et en plus je les 10 à 20 cents jeudi
c'est hier bonsaï a très bien marché a
commencé assez tard à 21h20 donc ça ne
change rien mais c'était sa demande
on en a parlé tous les deux on discute
beaucoup voilà donc c'était une demande
de sa part pour border un petit peu tout
ça va les régler vous avez une question
oui moi je moi je sais que vous étiez
vraiment heureux comme un enfant de la
venue de vincent lagaf vous l'avait
réclamé c'est formidablement bien passée
vous étiez très très heureux de sa
présence moi c'est simplement une
question affectif que j'avais envie de
vous poser c'est est-ce que vous avez
vous été peiné des déclarations de
vincent tout simplement alors des
déclarations de verson je sais pas j'ai
pas été peiné je vous dis franchement
parce que en fait il a toujours dit
depuis le début qu'il ne voulait
appartenir à aucune chaîne qui peut très
bien travailler sur si évident demain
sur tf1 s'il a un projet qui le botte
sur m6 etc
après c'est vrai que voilà il nous il
nous a prévenus des débuts après c'est
vrai qu'il avait fait deux strike au
départ mais on en a signé pour 15
prennent donc c'est vrai que sa fille
fait partie des figures maintenant
emblématique de ces mythes et je pense
et je lui ai dis franchement on s'est
parlé au téléphone que il doit être à
fond derrière ses 8 et que quand on est
sûr c'est vite pour moi maintenant
surtout quand on a une grosse exposition
comme ça on à fond sur ces 8 et on est
derrière la chaîne et on se dit pas
qu'on va aller sur tf1 ou ailleurs j'en
ai parlé de ça après lui il ne voit pas
comme ça il dit voilà moi vous avez vous
m'avez demandé mes services le jeu m'a
plu je vous hais
bien que pour que pour faire strike
après voilà si vous voulez que je fasse
d'autre chose dans l'émission je les
ferai mais en tout cas voilà je suis pas
là pour faire varier ou à celui qui le
payent le plus quand on fait quoi s'il
veut travailler en voulait le plus
offrant c'est pas une question d'argent
c'est une question de projet à qui il
reste dont il ay l'envi les mistral
il veut faire serait que c'est vincent
qui m'écrit il dit une dernière chose à
l'intention de monsieur le maire vous
qui pensez que je suis vénale et que je
pense qu'à l'argent voilà sachez que
lundi je pars pour la belgique pendant
trois semaines à prendre de tourner un
film dans le cadre du télévie pour la
lutte contre la leucémie
ceci dit l'indien se ne pensez pas menti
s'il vous plaît ne me plaît pas tous en
même temps
donc voilà je vous le dis le truc c'est
la cseries et prenait projet par projet
après question oui alors j'ai une
question ça enchaîne sur celle là est ce
que aujourd'hui sincèrement cyril est ce
que la gaffe a encore un avenir sur ces
oui franchement je pense que oui puisque
pour moi dans le jeu c'est le plaisir
que je pouvais trouver dans ce tract qui
fait un travail exceptionnel
moi je vais demander de faire un travail
pour nous sur cette émission qu'on a
qu'on a bâti et c'est vrai quoi là je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui c'est le meilleur
dans l'exercice dans cet exercice de
divertissement et de jeu pour moi il a
un grand avenir
sur ces 8 mais franchement il a un grand
avenir sûr c'est vite si si il joue et
qui livre là je suis avec ces 8es avec
personne d'autre
je sais pourquoi vous avez été aussi
sévère avec vincent je vous le dis c'est
parce que aussi vous vous êtes dit nous
on a foncé vite mon à fond corpore lui
il a la chance d'avoir 15 prime time
donc il est très exposé et il dit qu'il
peut aller sur tf1
il dit qu'il peut aller sur m6 dès qu'il
peut aller sur gulli et moi en courant
ou en courant oui en cours voilà donc
c'est si je dis que ça vous a un peu
choqué nabila outre le fait que pour moi
je pense qu'il est simplement le pris le
melon
voilà que l'accouplement il est très
bien placé pour savoir quand et les
quand on est avec une chaîne
on est avec une seule chaîne c'est c'est
comme ça c'est on s'engage pour être
blessants la chaîne merci oui moi ma
question c'est si ils arrêtent quand est
ce que le
le format continuer ce que strike va
continuer alors si la règle soit pas
pourquoi peut-être que strike continuera
sans vincent s'il a envie d'arrêter
mais pour moi c'est le meilleur là
dedans et j'espère qui va et qui va
continuer j'ai pas mathieu bon vous
savez pas très tendres parce que je
pardonne pas beaucoup et notamment je
pardonne pas le fait que quoi qu'il dise
on est et lui proposer parce que plus
personne ne proposait rien il avait
déglingué tf1 dans la presse et la
première chose pour remercier cet effet
le grand concours des animateurs et
ensuite c'est ce sentiment un peu de en
vrai je me resserre de 6 8 pour
retourner sur tf1 j'ai pris un peu la
tnt
moi je veux être sur la première chaîne
d'europe parce que je suis là ma
question il ay lilas il a une réponse
pour moi oui
alors ma question sinon c est ce que
très honnêtement je pense qu'on veut
répondre honnêtement vous ne regrettez
pas d'eux est un petit peu enflammé
après le premier d'avoir signé 15
émissions si vous aviez su son attitude
est ce que vous avez enseigné au temps
alors franchement je crois beaucoup au
format ça marche quand même très très
bien je vous le dis l'avant dernière
fille 700 milles avec les rip et donc
c'est le format est très fort je pense
que c'est toujours le redis la meilleure
personne pour ce format et je ne
regrette pas un instant
voilà que ces 8 met en place un
rendez-vous fixe le mercredi avec strike
parce que giuly les téléspectateurs
aiment l'émission il ya eu de très bons
retours sur l'émission la plaint qu'ils
ont fait ici j'aime beaucoup d'émissions
et c'est vrai que voilà à vincent joly
est excellent en dedans et pour moi
c'est le meilleur animateur de jeu alors
il vous a répondu monsieur de leurs maux
je pense que les années passées dans la
télé réalité ont eu un tel impact sur
vous que vous ne vous rendez même pas
leurs descendants
c'est à grand isle bien comme le dit à
rendre une carrière que vous ne vous
rendez même plus compte que les
innombrables critiques gratuites que
vous avez proféré à mon égard ont blessé
une personne et ses proches qui eux sont
dans la vie réelle je vous rappelle ce
tweet que vous avez plus publié le 26
novembre dernier aussi évidemment vous
comprendrez que je ne réponds pas à
l'autre crétin de non-stop people il ne
vit que de ça que des petits bugs
minable pour tenter d'exister
jaloux aigris et comme disait georges
bernanos les ratés ne vous rateront pas
vous voyez que vous êtes capable de
réflexion voilà il vous a répondu
marie est ce que je peux remettre une
petite dernière puisqu'on parle
d'élégance peut citer la sienne je vous
rappelle qu'un jour dans cette émission
j'ai dit je suis contre l'arrivée de la
gaze dans cette chaîne dans cette chaîne
est franchement j'ai fait ça comme ça
parce que je trouve qu'il n'a pas
forcément cette place le soir même vous
souvenez je me suis votre en scooter
vous êtes venu me voir et vous savez les
conséquences que ça a eu le lendemain
dans cette émission sur cette scène il a
dit hier de leurs mômes à critiquer il
est tombé en scooter bien fait pour lui
en direct
est ce que ça nous est ce que c'est
élégant
sinbad mais selon le monde est que les
élections c'est bon d'en dégager les
grands temps dans l'es2 en décembre
avait marqué aussi au dessus du massif
afin de marquer alors alors que
l'appétit des plus grands je voudrais
juste rien j'aurai youth répondre aussi
à un accord il lui répondit alors
version peluche yoplait question moi je
voulais simplement dire que la gaffe on
le connaît on était là elle était déjà
comme ça donc vous saviez sa
personnalité il avance par l'électron
libre
le mec il est très clair dans sa
démarche il a toujours été comme ça je
vois pas où est la surprise voilà alors
il a passé parce que celle-ci question
je te plaît trac elle d'abord mais juste
une remarque parce que moi je ne sais
pas quelle est la nature du contrat qui
avaient ou kylie a en dessous juste car
ce projet avec lui voilà sûr sinon maïs
en exclusivité chez nous aux terriens du
dimanche
tout le monde est sur d'autres médias
les humoristes en même temps sauf à
voile à faire
moix fait ce soir paris première et le
samedi les timbres m 10 c'est quand même
c'est une trahison ul ça ne choque
absolument personnes dont quelques
heures d'écart et animateurs de ces
différentes aussi c'est pas les mêmes
contrats je suis un peu d'accord auquel
il est animateur principal mais les
prises à balai sur moi je vous aime et
j'aime lagarde dont je suis tranquille
mais vous avez tout le monde mais c'est
en est aujourd'hui et qui selon vous
êtes dit au téléphone surtout alors ben
justement j'ai ou dire ce qu'on s'est
dit au téléphone
moi j'ai eu vincent longuement aussi eu
une heure au téléphone
voilà je suis on va jouer tout vous
raconter dans un instant et vincent à
une question m'a posé une question à
laquelle je vais répondre un instant je
vous le dis une dernière chose il me dit
j'aimerais te poser une question cyril
mon habit le chef d'orchestre de cette
émission pourquoi avoir laissé faire
pendant trois jours de suite une telle
animosité
alors tu que tu savais que j'étais à 20
mille kilomètres sans aucun moyen de
communication qu'est ce qu'il a fait
l'aventuré robinson sur tf1 pourquoi
est-ce que tu pensais que ce buzz ferait
la promotion de strike est ce que tu
pensais que ce buzz renforcerait nos
liens d'amitié et bien vincent on parle
je vais te répondre dans un instant je
vous racontais la discussion qu'on a eue
on veut donc vincent lagaf le fond où il
est parti également d'une interview sur
rtl ou voilà il a dit qu'ils visaient il
a fait des confidences et il a dit
qu'ils retournaient sur tf1 compte ils
voudraient regarde si tf1 me dis ton
idée d'émission de sports mécaniques
nous prend
on la veut le dimanche après midi j'y
vais en cours et si vous propose
finalement je sais que vous en avez
parlé avec eux de faire cette fameuse
adaptation du jeu de l'oie
j'y vais en courant affaire à suivre
mais tf1 ça reste votre maison de car
quand même beau temps et tu veux tu es
tu bouges du couple avec tf1 25 ans
c'est pas parce qu'en ce moment je suis
avec la voisine que je vais pas revenir
au bercail
je lis encore alors vincent géré c'est
aussi un mot à vous avez posé encore aux
questions il dit ah vous à qui je viens
de m'adresser à vous vous rendez compte
qu'on bosse sur la même chaîne et que
vous mettez en péril un programme
produit par votre patrese valérie en
revenant régulièrement sur cette
histoire là il a fait une sortie mais il
avance jamais masqué vincent ça fait de
même comme sur même sur ce plan non mais
même sur ce plateau il nous a dit je
suis ici même
j'ai un projet mais que de sports
mécaniques
j'aimerais qu'on me le prenne sur le
mail gérer alors ici on m'a demandé
aussi et je vais lui répondre à toutes
ces questions pourquoi j'en ai parlé
dans l'émission alors j'ai toujours
parlé de tout ce qui se passait au
niveau médiatique dans l'émission j'ai
parlé de mes émissions il m'est arrivé
de fracasser des émissions à moi comme
strike de donner vraiment mon avis sur
des émissions que je produisais et c'est
le jeu
si demain je ne parle pas de strike et
des déclarations de 20 sont dans tel ou
tel média on va me dire alors pourquoi
ils fracassent tf1 ou pourquoi il dit du
mal de telle ou telle émission sur
france 2 sur m6
et quand ça se passe sur ces 8 alors on
fait comme si de rien n'était on a
essayé on dit ah ben non on n'a pas vu
ça a été le truc qui a fait le plus
parler pour elle et surtout les blu ray
mais sur sur twitter sur les réseaux
sociaux sur facebook
ça a été le cas fait le plus parler
j'étais obligé d'en parler monde à 100
sinon je ferai passer pour un con toi
aussi la chaîne aussi été pmp ça
voudrait dire qu'on peut alors on en
parle nous il nous est arrivé de dire
des choses qu'on pensait sur thierry
ardisson sur son émission alors que
tirer moi et je vous le dis franchement
on s'entend thierry voilà que les tous
les jours au téléphone on s'entend hyper
bien et ils jouent le jeu en somme voilà
lui il peut dire des choses sur moi des
vannes
il a fait des vagues dans une émission
sur moi je le prends très bien et c'est
normal on parle de ses émissions quand
parfois il ya des choses qui me plaisent
au moins ou peu et voilà on dit les
choses on est obligé ims thierry m'a
toujours dit il m'appelle
d'ici un mois je n'en voudrai jamais tu
parles de mes émissions et qui est des
chroniqueurs qui donnent leur avis sur
moi qu'ils soient avec moi ou sont en
moyenne 10 et le jeu de ton émission et
je comprends le principe si tu ne le
fais pas pour ses 8 tu ne peut plus
créer votre modération
parce que si tu critiques que les autres
chaînes eh ben c'est pas possible donc
on est à un âge où dit on et impartiaux
dans cette émission on essaie d'être le
plus possible impartial que voilà que ce
soit les chroniqueurs ou que ce soit moi
gilles verdez non pour moi la gaffe il a
quand même fait une terrible erreur à
minimath communication sur le jv encore
ans donc c'est pour ça que j'ai regretté
ce que vous avez dit pas du tout et je
peux et je pense que lui devrait
regretter ce qu'il a dit il s'est pas
rendu compte de la caisse de résonance
que ça aurait six mois je ne veux
absolument pas personnellement je pense
qu'il s'est mal exprimé ce que c'est un
animateur que vous aimez mais beaucoup
j'ai dit du bien de lui
j'ai milité pour son retour et j'ai dit
du bien de ce train que j'adore vous
voyez même engueuler en me disant tu dis
trop de bien de strike c'est moi qui
produit à m'en fous que ce soit vous qui
produit j'adore cette émission je la
regarde
alors moi je vais répondre à vincent
dans un instant et j'ai un message à lui
faire passer à vincent oui vous est ce
que vous nous en voulaient d'avoir été
si virulent avec les rues basses en
ligue 1 française dans cette émission on
dit tout ce qu'on pense mais est ce que
là on a un peu dépassé les bornes
alors je vous dis franchement c'est vrai
que je vous lis vincent trouve qu'on a
été un petit peu loin et je peux le
comprendre il a été extrêmement blessé
c'est quelqu'un voilà qui avait qui
avait pas été à la télé depuis de
nombreuses années je vous dis il a
ouvert son compte twitter à ma demande
est là il est obligé de le fermer son
compte twitter précieuse est assez
propre non non non pas si si si bien
s'il vous plaît parce qu'il se faisait
insulter parce qu'elle avait des
messages c'est l'ajax est assez gênant
pour lui alors moi je dis toujours tout
ce que je pense mais après c'est vrai
que j'ai un petit peu de peine et j'ai
eu de la peine à paris vincent
maintenant je ne regrette pas un instant
ce que vous avez fait puisque je vous
dis vous serez toujours libre de dire
tout ce que vous voulez tout ce que vous
pensez et je vous dis je suis le
producteur de l'émission
donc si j'avais voulu et si franchement
j'avais été malhonnête je vous aurais
dit vous dites que strike c'est génial
que vincent c'est le meilleur animateur
du monde et que et iq et voilà et on
continue et on essaie de faire que
l'émission marche le mieux possible
on sait voilà on dit on m'a dit
exactement ce qu'on pensait des missions
et de vincent et ça sera toujours comme
ça que je produise émission pas sinon on
arrête et bnp ont fait une autre
émission où on va là on passe des images
et on rigole et on dit que tout est beau
et offrira un mot très rapide quand même
par dont cet homme a beaucoup de talent
c'est pas le problème il ne se remet
jamais en question
nous regrette de l'avoir tailler une
regrettent d'en avoir parlé mais à quel
moment là tout dit des bêtises dans une
émission est ce que lui pour aider ne
serait ce qu'une fois dans une interview
with immediate regretter je ne sais pas
ce que j sait pas très bien où j'aurais
peut-être dû dire merci peut-être à 6,8
oui effectivement ce trek maintenant oui
être sur tf1 c'était pas très très bien
ah pardon oui à la sks qu'à un moment il
s'est remis de temps en temps lui aussi
en question sur ses paroles qui ont été
très maladroite 16 tout n'est là qu'une
avancée ce qui est acquis ces paroles
mais ne s'accuse pas du tout lui
d'aborder des bêtises alors jeudi matin
dans l'émission de jean marc morandini
morandini monroe dîner live ils ont
remarqué que beaucoup de fans de tpm p
voilà et c'est vrai que merci d'être
aussi fidèle à cette émission avait
appelé au boycott de l'émission sur
twitter regardez total bizarre parce
qu'avais strike qui était diffusée sur
ces 8 et quand on regardait le fil
twitter de strike on voyait qu'ils
avaient énormément de fans de 6
l'avesnois qui appelait même au boycott
de l'émission en disant c'est un traître
il a trahi ses rives
il faut pas regarder son émission donc
je pense qu'en fait le gros perdant leur
histoire ça va être la gaffe parce qu il
en train de se mettre tous les fans de
tpm paix à dos et ça lui donne pas une
très belle une très belle image en tout
cas alors donc voilà donc c'est vrai que
il a ensuite annoncé dans tp il ya deux
semaines qui fait d'aller faire
laventure robot robinson prochainement
sur tf1 et c'est vrai que ça aussi voilà
ça fait un petit peu grincé regarde
surtout pas du tout surtout je vois que
tu vas faire l' aventure robinson sur
tf1 d'ailleurs tu parles vendredi tu
pars avec marine leur flotte eut pas
rond j'ai pas le droit de dire avec kids
je peux le dire ou sinon je serais je le
verrai
vendredi matin en arrivant à roissy
atelier du paradis fiscaux c'est fini
alors je vais je vais prendre des
questions twitter après je répondrai
donc je vous relire le sms que m'a
envoyée vincent et les questions qui me
posent at eu le sentiment que la gaffe
s'est servie de toi pour être à nouveau
dans la lumière et que dès le départ son
but ultime était de renouer avec tf1
alors joli mois au départ je suis allé
voir parce que je pensais je vous le dis
que c'était le meilleur pour l'émission
strike ça s'est très bien passé entre
nous on s'entend encore très très bien
et j'aime beaucoup humainement
franchement j'aime beaucoup
on s'entend bien mais c'est vrai que je
vous le dis et je le dis franchement
j'ai été un petit peu peiné quand il
parlait beaucoup de tf1 qui l'a alors
que bernard montiel la matière dès
qu'ils sortent des points soleil qu'à
son époque j'étais je vous le dis j'ai
été un petit peu peiné parce que je me
suis dit moi si j'amène vincent lagaf
sur ces 8 c'est pour construire une
aventure avec lui sur le long terme
et voilà qu'ils me disent moi j'ai envie
d'aller sur tf1 oui ça m'a un petit peu
peiné mais je ne pense pas qui s'est
servi de moi pour revenir et pour
ensuite partir sur tf1 je pense que le
projet de strike lui pris le plaisait
vraiment autre question s'il vous plaît
sur twitter la cité arrière qui m'avait
posé la question
sabrina est ce que toutes les émissions
enregistrées de strike seront diffusés
oui les émissions enregistrées de ce
travail seront diffusés d'ailleurs déjà
une ce soir qui est très très fort et le
jeu n'est pas du tout remis en cause que
le jeu est vraiment d'ailleurs vous êtes
invités dans un jeu invité je ferai la
spéciale halloween puisque j'adore me
déguiser
est-ce que vous avez une autre question
s'il vous plaît après je répondrais la
question de vincent lagaf ne penses tu
pas que les réelles motivations
profondes de la gaffe ne sont basées que
sur des chiffres et qu'il a juste cette
envie de succès et de reconnaissance
alors la strack en jeu ni le bilan de ce
tract est très très bon en audience pour
vincent lagaf il à faire très très beau
retour
quoi qu'il arrive voilà donc je pense
pas que ce soit ça mais je vous le dis
je les ai eus au téléphone et je vous
dire il m'a dit il m'a dit voilà cyril
est ce que tu sais ce que c'est qu'un
tarbes a qu'un connard
voilà il m'a dit eh ben c'est moi
aujourd'hui parce que je me fais
insulter toute la journée
aujourd'hui j'ai même pas envie de
sortir de chez moi parce que c'est
compliqué pour moi voilà et non
messieurs open on m'a arrêté avant la 6e
ou pellets laisser insulter ici aussi
sur twitter
non mais laissez nous rire lui il n'a
pas fêté des premiers temps il se met
sur twitter il se fait insulter il a une
famille qui en souffrent énormément
giuly est donc forcément aujourd'hui il
est pas voilà il est il des piles est
pas au top
vincent alors la question qui va poser
je vais répondre je vais vous redire son
sms
il m'a dit voilà et toi cyril alors il
nous a envoyé un nouveau truc je vous le
dis voilà donc timati et toi cyril mon
ami le chef d'orchestre de cette
émission pourquoi avoir laissé fait
pourquoi va laisser faire pendant trois
jours de suite une telle animosité alors
que j'étais à famille km pourquoi est-ce
que tu pensais que le buzz se ferait la
promotion de strike est ce que tu
pensais que ce buzz renforcerait nos
liens d'amitié pour nos liens d'amitié
ils bougeront jamais moi je vois là je
sais faire le distinguo entre le travail
et l'amitié et quoi qu'il arrive
voilà j'aime vincent lagaf j'aime la
personne et je serai toujours là voilà
s'il a besoin de moi et je pense qu il
encore un avenir
sur ces huit voilà pour en ce qui
concerne strike je suis pas là pour
faire jeu bien sûr qu'on a envie que
strike marque mais j'ai été obligé de
parler de cette affaire comme je voulais
dit
dans un souci de transparence même si je
suis le producteur de l'émission et que
voilà je comptais les j'adore strike
j'adore ce jeu c'est un jeu qu'on a on a
construit et c'est un jeu qu'on a monté
de toutes pièces
voilà maintenant je pense encore que
vincent lagaf est le meilleur là dessus
et je vous le dit vincent
quoi qu'il arrive nous soutiendra sur
s'est vite et la seule chose que je peux
te demander aujourd'hui et je pense que
c'est ce qu'attend le public également
cécité avec ses 8 soit avec nous à fond
et quoi qu'il arrive
ta famille cissé ces 8es ne lâchera
jamais comme on a lâché
jamais aucun animateur tu peux demander
à julien courbet à camille combal voilà
tous ceux mêmes qui sont partis
aujourd'hui la porte est toujours
ouverte pour eux et quoi qu'il arrive
site à fond avec nous eh bien on sera
toujours ta famille route soutiendra
toujours et je pense que c'est important
qu'une ça voilà
électronique heures je le redis encore
une fois les chroniqueurs de cette
émission disent ce qu'ils veulent il ya
toujours un contrepoids c'est pas pour
ça qu'il ne t'aime pas gilles verdez
t'adore matthieu delormeau un peu moins
mais on peut pas être aimé de tout le
monde ment vincent et quoi qu'il arrive
te dit tu es le meilleur sur ce jeu
éclate toi continue à nous faire marrer
le public t'aime et je te dis voilà je
pense que c'est ce qu'il faut retenir de
tout ça il ya vincent qui m'envoie un
message et bah tiens il me répond que ce
qui nous regarde
vincent lagaf voilà j'ai compris le
message
voilà et je t'aime fort mon vincent
voilà je voulais te dire et sache que
voilà tu es aujourd'hui le meilleur
animateur de jeu on est fier de t'avoir
sur ces 8 et nous ce qu'on veut juste
c'est que tu sois avec moi font parce
qu'on est fiers de taboye voilà on
t'aime toi